et sa beauté mode s fait des révolutions
déclamer des poèmes à l'arrière d'un bus
une idée originale pour susciter
l'intérêt des passagers de la ligne 400
une à destination ne mord pas ces
embuscades poétique se déroule dans le
cadre du printemps des poètes et sont
proposés par un collectif parisien est
prof d'histoire dans le bus ils ont
liberté totale soit collectif ou
individuel de dire des poèmes de les
chanter de l'es2 les criées de l'oeil au
relais de les murmures et à qui veut les
entendre et ils leur offrent chaque
personne qui écoute on leur offre un
marque page sur lequel il ya des pommes
des cris je suis pas poète mais j'aime
la poésie des belles paroles comme on
dit une quinzaine de comédiens répartis
en deux groupes se sont invités tout au
long de la journée sur plusieurs lignes
du réseau stibus peu créateur écouta les
propos la première fois qu'on l'a fait
j'étais un petit peu inquiète me disant
comment les clients vont recevoir 7
cette manifestation et ça s'est très
bien passé les conducteurs également les
conducteurs également apprécié parce que
ça les change c'est un petit peu d'avoir
de l'animation dans leur bus cette année
le printemps des poètes est placée sous
le signe de la beauté anthem inspirant
pour les comédiens par le monde est beau
le printemps est beau le la vie belle
et notre but est de leur rappeler la
beauté de la vie pour que le ressorte du
bus avec un sourire et la joie de vivre
c'est très pur